hello and welcome to this video pinguin
mr. Chamberlain is the opponent see
Alexa Gavriel off ok let's see what he
does against my banker gambit most
strong players take it let's see okay
play to the main line coolidge and a
seven here it's uncommon they usually
give it one move earlier
okay let's think about this Brooke a7s
is I think wrong actually 52 threatens
night be five and if it gives it one
more hmm ok I can also yeah midnight a
six doesn't make a whole lot of sense I
wonder if some Bishop e7 makes any sense
probably not and I rupees have now minus
k 7 Bishop de tu abhi sound ok I'll take
it with this
it's a very strange move water a 78
disposition really weird yeah it looks
it looks like white has gained something
here definitely
[Music]
okay so why am I going to play this I
need a little bit more pressure on the
queenside sell this may be preventing a
4 and maybe I can take a night a foul
really
okay let's ask them about this I think
you will go back not to h4 h4 I can
maybe take and play Queen 83 so he is
going back yes that is going to play one
okay my pain take this and if you now
goes a for i think i have c4
[Music]
and I need to break this open
immediately so a queen to be seven maybe
has a type the key on the B file that's
possible I currently don't see it but it
might be possible takes root X a 494
maybe try it from Knight to c6
and most extreme extreme amount of time
early on with this when I got so
irritated by his move water so Knight
comes to c6 shoot
maybe I get it back still looks shaky
though so I want to play route takes you
for
don't know if it helps him and wife
might be eight is going to play night
you for i guess i need to speed up here
one minute it's going to go 94 probably
anywhere now you would play 94 i guess i
don't know this strategy is correct here
from what I do what I do yet just try to
trade off the time learning the semester
burpees
have five against four is extremely
critical check yeah making it very easy
[Music]
you
yeah f6 es e 60 now that that game is
actually one in the opening because I
was so deeply irritated by his move
water and lost too much time black
resigns he's seven in this position
that's really irritating hmm that's a
move I don't know yeah I don't know it
because this move wins for black yeah
mmmm an idiot like a complete idiot this
and he cannot it cannot solve this whole
thing yeah it's this is a disaster okay
this is the reason why a seven is never
played because it's a big blunder yeah
of course I've thought about this move
but I couldn't really see why this is I
didn't continue here yeah I seven just
doesn't work and there's a reason
officer the thing is there is this
variation route takes Knight f3 + T
Queen 85 is bad because of this at
threatens 95 and this is what so deeply
irritated me and this means i cannot
take with the rope because that gives me
this dead-end leads to this pollution
and yeah queen 87 is not good yeah so he
basically blundered but I didn't didn't
didn't see how to make use of it yeah
this is just not a good good
the bank oh I mean I got some play but
it's not enough this is so he just keeps
the material here the night coming to
see success is just awful now that was
that that position out of the opening
was too bad yeah maybe I can fight
better he have it yeah i don't i don't
have to blunder right away Jim that I
cannot say if he's threatening me five
they're just just too bad and it was
very big opening playing about me one
and a half minutes and I don't play 94
okay oops I didn't want to do that okay
thanks for watching